the Joe Rogan experience I'm sure
there's a part of those programs too
right I mean when they shot doing that
that Japanese guy who's like worse than
[ __ ] Mengele Cameron what it's called
though it's so crazy the [ __ ] this guy
did to people and uh he got a they
wanted to know what he learned from his
human medical experiments oh so he they
let him off Jesus
I wish I remember the name of it the
Japanese uh it's but it's sokka's mostly
done to Chinese you know prisoners but
like you know cold and pressure and all
like it's [ __ ] grizzly dude yeah and
it's just he did so many aim were like
experiment he there's knowledge that
helps you make it be that they got same
reason we go put that great gold in the
record in space okay the people had
useful knowledge yes that crazy so
educate yourself if that's that like
look it's more important that you tell
us how many pounds of pressure it takes
to crush a little kid's head yeah we did
not know that officially officially tell
us what you got Christ it just let him
go imagine being that guy who killed
like hundreds of people and they just
let you go just imagine you like eating
ice cream at a diner sitting by yourself
I doubt you have the coffee nice cream
nobody even knows your ex sank you I'd
like one more please didn't they have
that of Harry Shearer easy that's the
Gustav guy Jesus Christ he led in
development and application of
biological weapons at you didn't 731 and
how do you say that word meant you go
man choke you oh man cuckoo oh I say
that man cuckoo but in Chico do you and
the Oh together how do you say that
probably basically to cool Mexico anyway
how are we saying during the second
sino-japanese war from 1937 to 1945
including the bubonic plague attacks Oh
in a tiny cities oh my god and the
planned attack against the United States
you know
holy [ __ ] man oh isn't that the one
where they would send the balloons
across the country yeah it didn't yeah
it didn't work these bats are something
to do with though the operation cherry
blossoms at night imagine this is my
plan operation cherry blossoms at night
biowarfare they're gonna drop the blind
play color of smallpox oh oh my god so
they were gonna do that to America in
balloons that were they're gonna do Dade
I think the thing I just come at us in
the through a most vulnerable way our
love of balloons balloons that was about
shiroishi nice balloons that was a big
song when I was in high school yeah the
girl was cute yeah okay these killed six
American civilians near Bly Oregon
I thought they dashed into a farm in
Medford Oregon and caused a short
circuit on the power supply power lines
supplying electricity for the nuclear
reactor cooling pumps in the Manhattan
projects production facility holy [ __ ]
dude did you know that
what were they dropping on him I had
balloons with bombs attached to him but
was it supposed to be with plague or
something well I don't know Jamie said
that was part of it but what I did hear
on there was an episode they did about
this on one of my favorite podcast which
is radio lab radio lab did a whole
series or a whole episode rather about
these balloons that people would find
these non detonated balloons and I think
people accidentally blew themselves up a
couple of times Wow yeah I think people
found them and then they've they've
found out after the war about the
project I think a bunch of them made it
here and some of them went off and some
of them didn't go off it's contaminated
fleas fleas oh my god that's so dark
Jesus Christ I'm so glad we're friends
with Japan now in China all the all the
bad guys in like I watched like the
local TV so everything is about of mean
Japanese general and like a brief
Chinese somebody is really yeah that's
like how like Nazis and uh we win
glorious bad like yeah Nazis are a pop
culture you go to likely it always uses
a villain that Japan is that to China
[Applause]